what was this mission to try and trans
Hitler there is a psychologist who's
working with the OSS who writes a report
on Hitler's personality trying to
understand who Hitler is maybe he has
vulnerabilities that can be exploited
one of the things that this psychologist
points out Henry Murray he writes this
report saying that Hitler has a large
feminine component to his personality
Stanley level reads this report and he
wants to figure out a way to use this to
the advantage of the United States
Stanley level comes up with the idea
that what if we inject female hormones
into the vegetables that Hitler eats if
he eats these hormones then that's
really going to push him over the edge
and his chest is going to grow breasts
this will decimate his fragile ego and
he's going to lose all of his
credibility and will somehow win the war
Stanley level in his Memoir he says that
he got some of these female hormones he
was able to give it to a gardener in
Germany who supplied the eagle's nest
with its vegetables where Hitler kind of
frequently went and so Stanley level
said yeah we got the sex hormones to
this person but we never knew really
what happened to it apparently it didn't
go through